this is the aftermath of a five point
eight magnitude earthquake homes roads
and other infrastructure damaged or
destroyed a Chanakya special thoughts
earthquake with sudden and so severe we
had no time to get out of our house the
next thing we knew part of the roof
collapsed we had to escape from a side
door we built our house eight years ago
and now it's gone here in Sangha we'll
äj-- a 20 minutes drive from the city of
mere fool people are still in a state of
shock the crib on our village is over
300 houses now some are gone and others
have sustained major structural damage
people are now sitting out in the open
soldiers and relief workers sent in to
carry out research and rescue operations
health salvage whatever is retrievable
the National Disaster Management
Authority issued a warning about
aftershocks and told everyone to remain
vigilant
the powerful earthquake was felt in most
parts of Pakistan but closer to the
epicenter you can see a trail of
destruction and people now don't know
whether it is even safe to go back to
their homes
Kamal Haider al Jazeera at Sangha
village near meeple Pakistani
administered fish me